hello welcome to the debate on sky news
i'm martin stanford
here's our take on developments brought
together from america the uk and around
the world tv news anchors lies an
exaggeration who can you trust i want to
apologize i said i was traveling in an
aircraft that was hit by rpg fire i was
instead in a following aircraft in a
message to his colleagues over the
weekend brian told us he's taking
several days off this broadcast amid
questions over how he recalled certain
stories he covered
can you survive on 7 25 debating the
case for raising the minimum wage
and in memory of joan rivers her fifth
avenue palace
going for sale for 30 million
so who can you believe nowadays the nbc
news anchor brian williams has admitted
telling an untruth by giving a
misleading account of being attacked
when he was reporting from iraq well now
he's been suspended for six months
without pay for what his company called
inexcusable actions well with me this
week as usual the democrat commentator
jeffrey robinson standing by for us in
new york and the conservative
commentator armstrong williams is in
washington now jeffrey perish the
thought we should ever embellish
anything in our lives have you ever done
this
i'm an old-fashioned journalist who
believes in old-fashioned journalist
ethics no you don't do that and he did
and it's a firing offense uh he will not
be back after six months i'm almost sure
of that armstrong williams this is not
just something that happened once it
happened often and if you read marie
dowell's piece of new york times over
the weekend
nbc employees felt that he was just a
liar the fact that they knew this and
the nbc executives like steve kappas and
others did not reign this under control
after there were complaints from nbc
producers a year ago that this is going
to be embarrassing and humiliating if
you don't do something about it you just
cannot blame brian williams yes he has
ultimate responsibility but you almost
also should look at his enablers who
played a role in this devastating black
eye to broadcast journalism
well at our studio in washington is the
media analyst of the daily beast and fox
news that's howard kurtz howard your
take on this did he have to go
well he certainly had to be suspended
punished because brian williams you know
essentially blew up his own credibility
i mean he didn't just tell an untruth he
told a war story about being hit uh in a
helicopter over iraq and this is 12
years ago and he's been telling various
versions of it since when he in fact was
not under direct and hostile fire and so
nbc looked like nobody was in charge
that williams himself had announced he
was going to take a few days off from
his top-rated newscast here in america
and finally the pressure got to be so
great the atmosphere so toxic that nbc
had to act whether he can come back i
don't know a lot of people are telling
me that it's very hard for somebody in
the news business sits in front of a
camera to get that credibility back
after it's been so badly tarnished
here's the weird thing the fib the
embellishment as you said happened 12
years ago
why did it take this long to be exposed
well in part because uh it wasn't until
last week
that brian williams retold the story on
his own nbc nightly newscast and that
prompted some army veterans who were on
that mission in iraq to go to a
newspaper here and say no no it didn't
happen that way he wasn't on that
chopper but he had told various versions
of the comedian david letterman and
others
it's surprising this didn't come out
earlier but also you have to say i mean
this guy is not a war correspondent
doesn't pretend to be he did take a risk
in going to iraq and flying an army
helicopter there was no need to
embellish the story and make it better
by saying his chopper was hit by a
rocket-propelled grenade and so
something propelled him to do that and
now he is paying a very heavy
professional price for that uh
misleading account jeffrey do you think
this would have had to happen anyway um
or is this actually because of the
competitive nature particularly of the
old beast of the nightly news the 6 30
show between the three monsters of news
that actually there was momentum there
that the others weighed in
on their rival
well the others have certainly played it
up as news stories but let me say this
if you look at cbs evening news nbc
nightly in the abc 6 30 news
what you're talking about is the
anchor's credibility that's all they all
cover basically the same stories they
all cover them uh with equal
professionalism and and really
sensational journalism terrific
journalism uh so you watch it because of
the man sitting behind the desk and his
credibility is everything once that goes
it's shot but there's something else
that hasn't been discussed about brian
williams that really bothered me and it
happened last december he is the
managing editor of or was the managing
editor of nbc news and nightly news he
was the boss he chose what stories to
put on the air and how to play them and
last december his daughter allison
starred in a live version of the musical
peter pan and he made that a news story
on his evening news three times
that i think is a hanging offense
because it shows absolute bad judgment
terrible judgment making his family a
story on a newscast where that is not a
news story but armstrong that happened
was anyone really that bothered
you know i tell you you know i i i think
you should engage how it curts a little
more because it bothers me and maybe he
needs to differentiate this for our
audience is there a thin line a
difference between embellishing
and outright lie outright consistently
lying because i mean i know we're only
talking about you're only talking about
what happened uh in in terms of the the
real story that he talked about on his
newscast but what about katrina what
about uh when he was in israel what
about when he was a firefighter it seems
as though this has been his i think this
is different from other broadcasts yes
people embellish and make themselves
look big but we're talking about
somebody who's very pathetic had a
pathology of just lying
there's a difference here
howard kurtz would you reckon three four
offenses over all the years that uh
brian williams has been both a reporter
and now anchorman does that make him a
bad guy
well actually he's a very nice guy very
personable guy he's a very funny guy one
of the reasons he's the most famous
presenter in america is because he goes
on a lot of comedy shows and shows his
lighter side on these other stories i've
been to new orleans with brian williams
after hurricane katrina whether or not
he embellished a little bit there or not
is in dispute some of these other
stories are in dispute but he slept in
the superdome the big stadium had no
power uh with you know hundreds or
thousands of people uh he covered that
story again
i see the iraq
lie is in a very different category uh
and i think but now once you do that and
once you lose that audience's trust sure
everything he's ever said or done is now
being questioned sometimes fairly
sometimes unfairly even whether he saved
one or two puppies from a fire when he's
a volunteer fireman in new jersey that's
the level this has reached that's why
nbc had to act and howard i have to ask
you in in in today's world and over here
in the uk hardly anybody
under the age of 30 is watching linear
tv anymore anyway
um and certainly channels like ours
channels like yours and the other
rolling news uh services in the united
states are
destinations of choice for many people
do these network news shows actually
matter much anymore howard
they they are relics but they still
matter and brian williams as the number
one guy of the major broadcast networks
here in the states nine million viewers
a night that's far more than any cable
show now the trend obviously is away
from everybody sitting around the dinner
table watching the news at 6 30 and
you've got to be online and all of that
but brian williams was the brand the
face of nbc not just because of that
newscast but because he as i say went on
all these entertainment shows and made
fun of himself and he was very good at
that so the question is are the
newscasts becoming
less relevant yes absolutely there is a
shadow of themselves from 20 years ago
30 years ago the era of walter cronkite
but still brian williams commanded the
biggest news audience on television in
this country so is nbc as a channel
jeffrey damaged by this
well no i don't think howard would know
better than i i don't think nightly news
made any money i don't think any of the
news programs make a lot of money i
think that they are simply prestige and
goes back to this great tradition of the
evening news of walter cronkite and eric
severide and and edward armaro and
huntley and brinkley and peter jennings
and even tom brokaw on and on and on
great journalist and once the
credibility is shot the program is
shocked because the whole program hangs
on that anchor's credibility uh brian uh
broke the vars it's not repairable
i'm strong do you think the networks
still matter and can nbc step over this
and get by
absolutely the networks matters sky news
matters it matters what jeff and i say
no matter what level or what we bring to
these broadcasts people expect us to be
truthful they expect us to be credible
and i think we owe them that um and i
don't think i don't whether it's brian
williams or anyone else and yes nbc
can recover but only if they look not
just at brian williams but they look at
the role that they play and allowing
this to continuously happening and not
protecting not only the brand of brian
williams but the brand of that peacock
nbc so listen i don't care whether you
are where you are whether you're a
writer whatever you are we all learn and
i do hope brian williams can come back
after six months because i think
redemption is something that is very
important for americans but i think he
should have been punished by being
suspended without pay and i think we can
all learn from this that people expect
us to be truthful and honest and when
you don't have that credibility why
should we believe anything you're
reporting or writing
howard let me put that point to you um
it's been announced he's taking six
months off that's what the bosses have
decided uh do you expect him back on air
after that hi here i am
well i don't think he can come back on
the air unless he makes a full
accounting of not just what he said
about in iraq but these other stories
including hurricane katrina and also he
needs to ask the american public's
forgiveness he botched the original
apology it was short it was quick it was
lame and it contained inaccuracy so it's
a very open question six months is an
eternity in television whether brian
williams will be able to come back what
bothers me though is there's been this
sort of mob online just you know calling
for him to be burned at the stake and
you know everybody makes mistakes this
was a very serious mistake he deserved
to be punished in a big way but there is
the question of his whole career to be
balanced against that i wonder if the
bigger talking point howard this weekend
is jon stewart stepping back
um you know i'm somebody who's i not
only been on john stewart's daily show
but have been the target of some of his
comedic barbs i not only think he was a
cultural phenomenon he influenced the
news business he was friends with brian
williams he had ryan wins on the show
all the time he changed the way the
quote real journalists act because of
the way he used videotape to make fun of
and also to
hold accountable politicians and pundits
made everybody else kind of lift their
game he did it the funny way we do it in
a little more serious way but he you
can't underestimate the impact that jon
stewart has had
howard kurtz thank you very much indeed
thanks
29 states in america have a higher
minimum wage than the federal government
insists upon in the last couple of weeks
the democrat-controlled illinois senate
passed a bill to raise the state's
minimum wage to nine dollars per hour
this year and to eleven dollars by 2019.
well to help us understand the
implications of raising the minimum wage
george faraday joins us he's the policy
director of the labor union change to
win what's the upside for employers
paying them more minimum wage george
well they get a better quality labor uh
primarily for the individual employer
uh and several large employers uh
including gaap um
uh have uh raised the wage for just this
reason and they they say they they need
uh better customer service they need the
best labor available and they're going
to pay for it
so why set it um as low as even the
federal government does why not lift it
even further if you want to take that
argument one step along the line
well we we would certainly uh advocate
doing that in our organization um
and uh i mean a very striking statistic
is that if the minimum wage in america
had kept pace not just with inflation
but with productivity since uh its peak
in the sixties would now be at twenty
two dollars an hour
uh which tells you just how far workers
have fallen behind over the last forty
years
well let's bring in jeffrey and
armstrong who are still with us from
respectively new york and washington
jeffrey is this affordable
yeah of course it's affordable in fact
it's very good for everybody now the
usual canard that you hear is oh no no
you raise the minimum wage you uh you
increase unemployment not true in fact
what happens when you raise the minimum
wage has been a result of a study that
the us department of labor did when they
looked at 64
other studies and what they found was a
higher hourly rate
reduces the expense of employee turnover
increases productivity fosters positive
attitudes and improves attendance since
such things as transportation health
care and child care are are taken out of
the equation it's good for everybody
so i'm strong it's high time this was
done right
you know i i i so disagree with george
it's not funny you know raising the
higher the minimum wage makes workers
more expensive it certainly does not
make them more productive one has really
nothing to do with each other in fact i
speak as an employer who has hundreds of
employees and the minimum wage to some
people is a further insult actually and
it's basically get the people the
workforce to get skills to internship to
to find mentors and to really develop
the person they want to become whether
it's an entrepreneur whether the
companies that they want to work for and
develop useful incredible skills that
can help them in the long run to make
the argument that raising minimum wages
make workers more productive it's
ludicrous obviously you've not owned the
business uh the people that you're
talking to only support the mindset that
you have right now because it makes them
more expensive and i can speak firsthand
not only for me but many business owners
across this country george faraday
well i think you have to look at the
impact on the entire economy which we
haven't done yet uh and
the proportion of uh of the economy
that's going to work as pay has fallen
by 10 percent in the the last 20 or so
years which is a trillion dollars in
last demand so for the economy as a
whole if the lowest paid workers were
getting a bigger share that would be a a
massive increase in in demand at a time
when uh
fiscal and monetary policy aren't able
to deliver those kinds of that kind of
boost armstrong i know there's plenty of
studies going on here the economic
policy institute just one organization
but they put out a paper saying
pay folks 10 an hour 10.10 i think is
their recommendation that would save the
government 7 billion a year because you
wouldn't have to do so many state
handouts and benefits doesn't that sort
of argument make sense armstrong
no listen
i i don't want to give the impression
that employers like myself are not for
helping people make more money because
we understand that is important but what
these low-skilled workers need they need
skills they need more skills many of
them out of high school what high school
is producing in colleges or producing
today many of these kids cannot even
work they don't even understand what
work ethic and discipline is a lot of
times employers have to spend time
mentoring and and you make it an
investment them where you end up getting
them to the place they need to be to be
of value to the company then they end up
going someplace else i mean there are so
many nuances here that you can't even
begin to describe in terms of making
that employee valuable the bottom line
is more important for that employee the
required skills and access to real
resources that can enhance them in the
future for their future jobs in terms of
the short term they need more of a
apprenticeship it should not really be
about money
jeffrey
pathetic answer absolutely wrong
pathetic answer this is not only about
high school kids working on weekends
this is about second wage earners and
families this is about retirees this is
about real people not just teenagers who
are out in the workforce who deserve a
living wage who benefit from a living
wage and the employer benefits i mean
it's a simple thing the department of
labor did a study of 64 other studies
not just one 64 other studies and they
said it does improve productivity it
does improve everyone's lifestyle
including the employers and i tend to
believe them before i'm going to believe
armstrong at this point
isn't there george faraday a moral case
for a minimum wage that it is the decent
thing for an affluent successful society
to do
well i think that's true and i i think
when you look at the uh the polling uh
data that uh 75 of americans support uh
a major increase in the uh in the
minimum wage including majority of all
republicans and i think it's a it's a
very american way of addressing uh the
the problem of poverty uh and working
people's standard living falling behind
i'm strong
but the problem the problem with the
problem with that argument and i
understand the point that george is is
trying to make but i think that george
and i may agree with this but the people
that you're trying to help that you say
that are in poverty uh below the poverty
line are not the ones ending up with
these low uh minimum wage jobs they're
just not you have many people especially
the economy that we had two or three
years ago where people were desperate to
find employment you found lawyers and
engineers waiting in line at places like
mcdonald's and other places and so other
work in other words when these low
minimum wage jobs for 10 and 12 hours an
hour were available they were scooped up
by people who overqualified so the very
people that you talk about that you're
trying to help are not the people
because that will end up with these
minimum wage jobs in the first place
why is it nonsense jeffrey
oh it's total nonsense i mean come on
don't be ridiculous you look at the
people not just the minimum not just the
the the uh
uh
ill qualified
you look at the people who are working
minimum wage and they are second family
earners they're the wife of the husband
going out uh trying to help the family
these people need a lift up and when you
help them it's not a question of
bringing them out of poverty it's a
question of bringing them up to what is
called the the national poverty line and
getting them above that line and that is
good for everybody it's good for
themselves
minimum wage jobs in the first place
you're clueless yes they are you have
never run a business you have no idea
what you're talking about absolutely
go to any shopping mall
at the retirees every day it is not true
george faraday the la mayor
eric garcetti recommends 13 an hour
is a fair wage uh is that affordable
that's quite a hike even what you're
talking about today
well in a in a
a city like la which is uh a a rich city
with a lot of highly paid workers it
would seem uh very affordable
and as i said if
it kept if the minimum wage you kept
place with uh productivity uh in other
words if you know but the growth of the
american economy would be 22 dollars an
hour so
to
so 13 is is
still half of that so why is it that in
the 1960s
uh no one
should
was required to work for uh such a small
slice of the economic pie
but and now we don't feel we can do that
i mean the other thing that factors in
here is is a lot of discussion i think
as to whether this should actually be a
state-by-state matter
and um some states as we know have
minimum wage either said at federal
level or below or above and everything
else and some of them like their
independence to be able to do that isn't
that appropriate so if you don't like
what the minimum wage is in some part of
the country you can always go and live
somewhere else
well i think uh i mean
there's another way of raising wages
which
may be more appropriate in some parts of
the country and and for uh occupations
that aren't
uh uh at the minimum wage level right
now and that's collective bargaining and
that allows workers uh to
uh determine the the the wage level that
is appropriate for their business um if
they're empowered to do so with uh uh to
bargain with their employers and that's
something which has
declined in america in the in the last
40 years but uh
we believe the president could take
action to uh to promote collective
bargaining once more using
the vast uh spending power that he has
in the private sector economy where uh
public procurement is over 11
uh of the economy
george faraday policy director of change
to win thanks for being with us today
next the lavish and palatial condo that
was home to the late jone rivers for 25
years is now up for sale the 11 room
penthouse occupies three floors of new
york's upper east side the home was
originally built in 1903 for a family of
gilded age millionaires and socialites
and for 28 million you too can enjoy the
unique louis xiv inspired decor
uh you know even if i had the money
armstrong i'm not sure if it's really me
what do you think
uh
i think jeffrey should buy it but
however
i couldn't resist that
so let's uh i'm sure
um jones daughter melissa has a reason
for selling it i'm sure there's a lot of
pain
you know it's surprising that she's held
this uh this massive unit for so long
that she'd want to sell it because it's
probably if she did not get sucking
mortgages on it she's probably paid off
for the debt and it's probably mortgage
free
and i'm sure when you have a tax estate
and you go through lawyers and and taxes
there are issues that you have to deal
with where a lot of money must be paid
and i'm i'm sure you will find a buyer
for it is joan rivers but spending 28
million dollars i got to tell you
something like i said i'll leave that to
my brother jeffrey it's all yours
jeffrey
well coming in first of all would you
would you i'm not sure if you got the
money in the bank jeffrey but would you
would you go upper east side and you
even if you did
i'm writing a check right now and i want
armstrong to know there is a guest room
for him
not a problem
the only difference
the only difference between joan's place
and my place is that she has straight
bookshelves and i don't that's the only
uh the only difference listen i i
i met her in 1966 when i was a staff
writer on the mike douglas show which
was a talk show and she was joanie in
those days and she's a wonderful woman
she really was i i liked her a lot we
would bump into her over the years she
had struck it big on the tonight show
and was doing stand-up at a time when
women were not doing stand-up and she
was very funny she was also extremely
accessible
my wife bumped into her in london and
about three months later in miami
airport she came up to my wife joan came
up to to aileen and said i know you
where did i meet you before i mean she
was that accessible and that fun uh we
went to a party one night where she
entertained and she was paid 100 grand
for a stand-up act
and she was filthy absolutely filthy she
had missed the mark because it was
families and there were kids in the
audience and she really blew it that
night
but i also bumped into a man who had
been engaged to her for six or seven
years man her own age and i said why
didn't you get married and he said it
was all about the prenup i said what
about the prenup he said joan presented
him with a piece of paper that said
everything i john rivers bring to the
marriage is mine and everything you
bring to the marriage is also mine and
that ended that
what
oh yes good
that's a great deal you know you know
one thing
let me just say one thing that she was
picking up 25 mil a year in the fashion
business with qvc selling jewelry i mean
her fashion company was a billion dollar
company so melissa is not wanting for uh
for money and it's not a question of i
have to sell the apartment i think the
will was 135 million dollars i think
that's what she left melissa so okay
guys we're going to leave it there for
this week thank you so much jeffrey and
to armstrong thank you and thank you for
watching that's it for this edition of
the debate until next time goodbye
you